it's an automotive icon with a history
that dates back to the 1950s now it's
undergone some improvements the Mercedes
SL is a powerful engine a nine-speed
automatic transmission five dynamic
drive programs and the suspension is
equipped with an active curved tilting
feature the SL has always been a
top-of-the-line touring roadster and the
new model continues that tradition we're
going to test an AMG sl63 that has a
power output of 430 kilowatts automotive
journalist available mont will put the
car through his paces I think the way
that that's developed the style of the
ass out into this of a more modern shape
it's still got the cues of the big the
big grill at the front but it now fits
with them much more and more modern
Mercedes style i think is worked really
really well he's yeah a nice resolved
shape it looks very very elegant as well
one feature that makes everyday driving
more enjoyable is that you can open and
close the roof while you're on the road
provided you don't exceed speeds of 40
km/h
when you open the trunk the folding deck
pops up automatically and the partition
in the luggage compartment slides back
all of this makes it easier to load and
unload your gear
you can almost hear the power of the sls
5.5 liter twin-turbo engine our test car
made it from a standing start to 100
km/h in just 4.1 seconds the SLS
automatic speed limiter kicks in at 250
km/h but you can boost that to 300 with
the AMG drivers package the SL comes
equipped with sport and comfort mode
options the car feels really stable both
on the open road and in curves will says
it was a pleasure to drive particularly
out in the countryside
really really nice roads fantastic
scenery and some sort of like lovely
sort of switchbacks and hairpin bends
and some really great fast colors as
well some sweeping corners to some of
the some of the sweet go the longer
corners where you can really feel the
curve tilt as well which was really nice
to solve yeah you can't understand how
that was a little bit better through
some of the quicker corners the SR
glides through curves as though the car
was on Rails the world did have a bit of
a problem with the SL steering I think
the steering can feel a little bit a
little bit odd there's a little bit of
vagueness sort of fun for an end when
your particular sort of round the dead
ahead position but once you're sort of
moving the rest of the car is very well
resolved with the steering so that even
though the steering you don't feel an
awful lot it feels very it's in tune
with the rest of the car to accept so
you can get some feedback to all the
other elements through the seats into
the suspension the F cells interior is
pure luxury including the leather
steering wheel cover
the ventilation nozzles on this edition
of the SL recall the design of previous
models the SL sells for about one
hundred sixty-two thousand euros in
Germany leather sport seats included
the SL comes with five drive select
modes you can switch from one to the
other depending on personal taste and
road conditions all when all will says
the new and improved Mercedes SL is a
lot of fun to drive
I think the revisions they've made to
the new SL has turned it into a really
sort of great sports car now as well
rather than just being Cruiser which was
very good at before it still does that
now but it also can excite a bit more
though than it used a
a muscular looking front end and a
striking air scoop are not the sort of
accessories you'd expect to find on a
station wagon but they're a perfect fit
with a Subaru levorg the name levorg is
a combination of the words legacy the
card replaced plus revolution entering
often vegan auto tester Android
Zimmerman says a wagon is great for
vacation driving these days they look
more sporty than they used to like the
four-wheel drive Subaru levorg it's
practical too you just pull back the
cover and then you can reconfigure the
luggage compartment to meet your needs
inborn fast on and with hits in bits and
Busta once you've removed the middle
section and the side panels you can
store the cover in the base put the side
panels back and you're good to go that's
Mitchell titled off this way you don't
have to leave the compartment cover at
home when you go on vacation it's a
really practical design so let's load
some stuff the trunks capacity is 500 22
liters and it's 104 centimeters deep so
there's plenty of room that's the title
andriy says the last thing he's going to
load is our camera tripod bag it
wouldn't fit into most trunks because
it's so long here too it's a little long
but that's no problem with a touch of a
button the problem is solved the back
seat folds down to make even more room
and were ready to go but I top five
the levorg design is based on the subaru
impreza but it's a cut above that model
the levorg sells for just under twenty
nine thousand euros complete with
four-wheel drive and automatic
transmission the product from the vault
Andre really likes the levorg suspension
it's quite stiff you feel some of the
unevenness in the road he says and
larger bumps are best avoided otherwise
it could get a bit uncomfortable but
because the suspension is stiff the
levorg is quite low to the ground giving
it great stability it has a relatively
low center of gravity so it can handle
even sharp curves easily Khun Danai
vogue I existing coal from the wife of
ed that's mine a mine nozzle Andre has a
minor complaint about the CVT
transmission he says it causes problems
while he's driving through a curve he
takes his foot off the gas while driving
into the curve but then he's coming out
of it and tries to speed up the car
takes a few seconds to react the levorg
is available in three customized models
the car is a power output of 125
kilowatts and can move from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour an eight point nine
seconds it's got a sporty look and feel
but Andre feels Subaru could make a few
improvements here
lets me AB I'm evolved you'd like to see
more choices for the engine and
transmission right now all you can get
is a 1.6 litre engine and the CVT anti
says he'd welcome a bigger more powerful
engine and the manual transmission on
the other hand he likes the way that you
can customize the levorg interior is
about way exclusive the color we're in
right now has the red and black color
option says Andre there's a little red
stripe in the steering wheel so you can
see when you're driving straight ahead
godsdammit mcfuzz is each vonda's link
our goddess did and you've got nice
Alcantara covering on the wheel too
Fritzi focus their schroon on motto it's
little things like that that put the
levorg interior closer to that of a
luxury model like a BMW porn audi or duh
OD off stag busting in home and get so
what does andre think of the Subaru
levorg overall
as affirmation consistent he says it's a
great car for travel but Subaru could
change a few things to make it a sporty
or vehicle still overall it's a very
practical car I guess that's our car man
mutters courage says a plug-in hybrid
car like the VW Passat GTE is a great
thing you can make all your local trips
with zero emissions and still have a
conventional engine available for longer
journeys but if you forget to charge it
up at home you'll have to look for a
charging station and then wait yeah from
the SU game is get in deutschland on
state system leave them out of deep
binder in the box the Passat GTE takes
around two and a half hours to fully
charge at a public station like this a
process that takes over four hours at
home an electric mode the car pulls away
with barely a sound powered only by
electricity from the battery
well does get lot here Martha says the
car has a range of fifty kilometers
according to the manufacturer so for
cities that aren't so large the electric
mode is fully sufficient but as he
points out the driver needs to take
particular care pedestrians and even
pets can't hear the car coming so they
may just pop out into the road without
warning vayas is even neat cool apart
from fully electric mode the GTE also
offers the battery charge mode here the
car is powered by the gasoline engine
which also charges the electric battery
at the same time that's useful for
longer trips especially on the freeway
in hybrid mode the car itself determines
which drive version is used drawing on
the electric battery as much as possible
in all modes energy is recovered during
braking and it's stored in the battery
fell off that Longstocking montes says
that when you're driving on country
roads in hybrid mode there's very little
difference to a normal pissant he's
driven Passats with various kinds of
engines and the experience is pretty
much identical the only thing you notice
here he says is that the suspension is a
bit stiffer because the car has to carry
the added weight of batteries electric
motor and all the control electronics
the most money any inspections begin ok
I can cause I want the one difference
that you notice immediately is on the
dashboard there's no rev counter on the
left-hand side like with other cars
instead it has an energy gauge which
shows you whether the battery is
charging or how much power you're using
but unlike other hybrid automakers VW
still gives you a small rev counter down
below that's because the GTE like other
VW models comes with a dual clutch
transmission and not a CVT transmission
the Passat GTE is powered by a 1.4 liter
TSI gasoline engine offering 115
kilowatts of power and an electric motor
with 85 kilowatts working together they
combine to offer 160 kilowatts VW says
gas usage is 1.7 liters for 100
kilometers but during our test drive we
use nearly seven liters of gas although
admittedly Montes did hit the gas pedal
quite a bit
then let us know that he says if you
like things a little speedier or you
just want to pass someone you press the
gte button that changes the way the
motor and engine respond also the
steering changes slightly and if you
have the optional dynamic chassis
control the dampers are also adjusted
for a sporty a ride from the outside the
GTE looks almost identical to a normal
passat only the GTE logos on the front
side and rear revealed that it's a
plug-in hybrid along with the blue
electric design line on the radiator
grille the hood conceals the power
center with its dual heart with the
battery and electric drive the GTE is a
whole two hundred eighty kilos heavier
than a purely gas-powered 1.4 liter
passat inside there are GTE logos and
blue stitching in the upholstery and the
find ambience light strips and the doors
are also in GTE blue that's laden monta
says it's obviously an advantage to
charge the car first if you want to keep
your emissions down and that can easily
be done at home this is a european plug
but there are plugs available for every
market that's good if you don't want to
set up a charging box in the garage but
if you don't have your own house but
live in an apartment block for example
then charging your car is going to be a
problem that's one of the reasons why
montes wouldn't choose this car
personally he also feels that although
driving with zero emissions is great it
only works if you're always driving just
short distances and can then charge your
car up in between then there's the high
price which is another drawback price
des matériaux also improved for each dog
has mostly how open for than national
import money
the VW Passat GTE sells for just over 45
thousand euros in Germany by comparison
gasoline models start at just under
twenty six thousand although that's with
far fewer features so there's a huge
price difference perhaps not the best
way to promote the sale of plug-in
hybrids
it has proven to be the ultimate
bestseller the opel corsa has been on
sale for 34 years in that time for
generations of the course have come and
gone with over 12.4 million vehicles
sold the fifth generation is now on the
market and our mana mana well Schaeffer
is about to take one for a spin I was
eternal he thinks it looks pretty chic
from the outside he finds one fact very
interesting that both the 3-door version
and the five-door we're testing have the
same wheelbase and overall length time
to find out how it drives so am i TVNZ
Sofia's the new course it's just a
fraction over 4 meters long we're
testing a 1.4 liter gasoline version
with 74 kilowatts of power that allows
the Corsa to go from zero to 100
kilometers an hour in 11 seconds and
reach a top speed of 185 km/h our model
cells were just under 17 thousand euros
in Germany
does five active amano says the new
courses suspension has nothing in common
with its predecessor all the components
are new and he can feel that too he says
it feels much better planted on the road
that's partly because the body now sits
five millimeters lower the newly
developed steering also makes a big
difference
the cabin is simple and uncluttered in
our bottom of the line test car you
won't find any particularly innovative
features or expensive looking fittings
but the interior offers plenty of space
all around after reading the technical
day that you Manuel wanted to know what
285 liters of cargo space felt like and
he finds that even though he's 1 meter
80 tall he has plenty of room to sit and
if that's not enough you can fold the
seats down to get 1120 litres of space
that's a duck hunter folate
danaya Colin says the new Corsa offers a
variety of driver assists some included
in the standard features one of those is
the city mode which gives you extra
power assistance on the steering when
driving at lower speeds then there's the
hill start assist which stops the car
rolling back for two seconds when you
set off features that other car makers
charge a lot for mandolin hairston teeth
in etosha life all in all the cores a
success story looks set to continue now
in its fifth generation
today the Porsche 356 numbers among the
truly classic sports cars in 1948 it
became the first automobile to proudly
bear the Porsche name before then
Ferdinand Porsche had developed cars for
various other brands at the porsche
design and engineering firm he'd founded
in 1931 and stood guard
to ask the positive but our classy car
expert Christophe Bauer tells us that
the first Porsche wasn't actually built
in stuttgart but in the Austrian town of
community near the end of the Second
World War the company had moved its
entire operations there to escape the
constant bombing raids and the 356
wasn't the brainchild of patriarch
ferdinand porsche rather I was his son
fairy who created the sports car out of
VW parts his father praise fairies work
and said he wouldn't change a single
screw wouldn't mind kinda shall they
happy unless c'mon
Ferdinand Porsche was one of the auto
industry's pioneers starting in 1897 he
developed electric and hybrid engines an
all-wheel drive model and trend-setting
mid-engined race cars like the Aastra
Daimler Sasha and the auto union Silver
Arrow
not to mention the legendary Volkswagen
Beetle the first Porsche that ferry
designed together with his father's
committed team of engineers was based on
the VW Bug
but in Christophe tells us that early
versions of the Porsche 356 had a
souped-up Beetle engine under the hood
which barely produced 40 horsepower
that's not really enough for a sports
car but he says it's fun all the same
the car is clever aerodynamics and
lightweight construction when to reach
140 kilometers an hour during the 17
years the 356 was produced Porsche
continued to make improvements this
super 90 convertible from 1960 is among
the most fully perfected versions it's
1.6 litre 90-horsepower engine is over
twice as powerful as the motor and the
original 356
as I so kristef says the rattling sounds
the car makes while warming up remind
him a lot of the VW Beetle but the boxer
engine shows it's true colors when the
tachometer reaches around 3000 rpm then
things really get moving and it can
hungrily progress to 5500 revolutions
per minute for not too hun he could
become addicted to the sound to it makes
him want a double D clutch even when he
really doesn't need to Susan gasps oh
boy says gets me the next
as it in Porsche pesek Krishna feels at
the Porsche 356 is not only a blast to
drive it's a feast for the senses to the
big white steering wheel the leather
seats these buttons here everything
gives you the impression of being made
to last the car's body was designed by
engineer Erwin commenda who'd already
given shape to auto unions Grand Prix
sports cars and the VW Beetle Christophe
says 356 is a true milestone in
automotive history that formed the basis
for Portia's design language he says any
new 911 is really just a modern variant
of the 356 that is the anglican east
analyst as animal diana very anti
disguise x infinity
its face is immediately recognizable the
round headlights and prominent wings
have essentially become part of Porsches
DNA the gently sloping rear is also a
Porsche specialty although the teardrop
aerodynamic design is now seen as David
the ignition is found to the left of the
steering wheel the tachometer is
centrally located and the ergonomics are
stellar these features Porsche drivers
have come to know and love all came from
the 356 thus hath society Christo says
the heart of the 356 can be found back
here while the first 356 is used beetle
engines this one was already fitted with
a four-cylinder 1.6 litre Porsche boxer
engine it boasts under head cams and
generates 90 horsepower in part thanks
to these two Solex carburetors the
standard engines had 60 and 75
horsepower there was a 130 horsepower
variant with a very complicated vertical
shaft engine but he says this here is
the finest one you can get the boxer
engines are viewed as reliable and long
lasting then as now Porsches are often
known as sensible sports cars which
makes them unique
I son noise Christo says that when
Portia announced it would be introducing
a successor model fans an automotive
journalists claim that a new Porsche
could never outdo the old 356 well the
911 has certainly made more than a few
friends over the years and as the
forefather of the 911 and the first
Porsche ever the 356 is definitely an
automotive milestone definitive and
Milan Stein the automobile 60
to be it's still a pleasure to take a
356 convertible out for a spin after the
356 was discontinued in 1965 Porsche
buyers had to wait until nineteen eighty
two for the introduction of the 911
convertible until they could once again
feel the wind in their hair
you